hi I'm NASA astronaut Kjell Lindgren and
I just returned from five months on the
International Space Station as a flight
engineer on expedition 44 and 45 I'm
standing here at Johnson Space Center in
Houston Texas and I've got some
questions from kids in kindergarten
coming from an iPad so let's let's take
a listen and see if I can answer these
questions how do you know whether went
to sleep because you don't know where
when it's lighter data because you're
not on the earth
well that's a great question you know
when we're in orbit we're actually going
around the earth every 90 minutes so we
see 16 sunrises and sunsets
so our clock on the International Space
Station is actually synchronized with
Greenwich Mean Time and we have a
schedule that tells us at 6 o'clock in
the morning it's time to get up and when
it's time to go to sleep and that way
all the control centers around the world
know what to expect know when we're
available for work and when not to
bother us float away
that's because gravity is still working
in space we call it you know
weightlessness or we call it zero-g but
that's not entirely true gravity is
actually what's holding the space
station in orbit around the Earth the
space station is traveling so fast
horizontally that it is missing the
earth as it goes around it's just kind
of curving in the earth as it as it's
flying around I have not seen an alien
space but what I have seen was the
aurora on the earth you just kind of see
it over the horizon but in space that
green light was swirling like an active
fog and it's absolutely beautiful and
one of my favorite sites during my
mission is there any aliens on the moon
- I have no idea I don't think so I
didn't get to go to the moon so I didn't
I didn't get to investigate my question
what you eat on a space station things
most of our food is repackaged and
pre-prepared so it comes in little bags
that have to be heated up or it comes
dehydrated and needs to be rehydrated
with hot or cold water we do have cargo
vehicles that are bringing food water
and other supplies up to the space
station to replenish the supply up there
one of my crew members was Japanese
astronaut kimiya Yui I would often try
to trade with him so that I could get
some of his rice and import curry so
having tasty food on the space station
is really important I would used to make
cheese burgers out of rehydrated beef
patties cheddar cheese spread and then a
tortilla and putting some mustard and
ketchup on there and that was kind of a
faux cheeseburger that I enjoyed having
on a weekend what I think to lock in
Spain well walking in space there's two
aspects to that when we're inside the
space station we don't actually even
walk we float and so we actually use our
hands quite a bit to move ourselves
around now to walk outside the space
station we will put on that big puffy
white suit it'll be pressurized inside
so it's giving us oxygen it's removing
the bad gases like carbon dioxide it's
controlling the temperature and provides
us really a mini spaceship to be inside
of while we're outside doing repairs or
installing equipment and that is an
amazing experience to get to see the
earth and the space station from the
outside just separated by one panel of
plastic thank you for your questions